we are really thrilled about our next
guest the moment we walked in the studio
we're all like
actors john bernthal and jamie hector
they are best known for their roles in
popular tv shows like the walking dead
and the wire and now they're teaming up
to star in a new series it's called we
own this city based on a book by the
same name it's by the same team that
brought us a wire back in the day and
also takes place in the lovely city of
baltimore the limited series inspired by
real life events chronicles the rise and
fall of baltimore police department's
gun trace task force where corruption as
you can see or have heard was rampant
hector plays a homicide detective and
bernthal plays a police sergeant at the
center of the corruption now in this
clip he briefs the department on the
task force
you don't worry about going out on the
street and ending up on someone's viral
video sergeant jenkins hey as long as
they get my good side
ladies and gentlemen what you see here
this is a result of one raid on one
house in collington square now we are
the gun trace task force we get guns off
the streets what we do now with a little
more personnel a lot more overtime
there's no telling the effect that we
could have reducing the surge of
violence in this city
john bernthal and jamie hector join us
for their first broadcast tv interview
together it's good to see you guys
together
bravo bravo bravo gentlemen john i'm
going to start with you because you play
such a jerk
i know and everybody that knows you says
that you are so fantastic
so how did you prepare because you start
out with this role where you were
talking non-stop the first part for five
minutes straight and you have such
swagger and such arrogance and such blue
i mean how did you prepare for this uh i
i look i i i just uh enormously
enormously grateful to to to be a part
of the show and part of this team um the
wire and you know what what you guys
accomplished uh it's just it's
undeniable and it's um
that show has so much resonance i think
in this country and then i think um when
you when you look at how much residents
it has in the city of baltimore i knew
that that would provide us access
uh
in this uh really just unbelievable way
so um
i knew that that that going in and and
being part of the wire team it would uh
open us up to tell this unbelievably
sensitive story and and the police
department the the police department of
the city of baltimore they really opened
up they were helpful but i still don't
understand how you were able to prepare
to play such a jerk so well
seriously did you
i am curious about your process well
look i think it's really important for
me to um the first conversation i had
with david simon he says look we can't
play a monster here you know you got to
play a human being and it's it's really
important i think to not completely
judge your characters and and to try to
find a bit of connection and i will say
about wayne jenkins to a person whether
it was the drug dealer that he was
selling drugs with on the street whether
it was other officers whose careers have
really been upended by the the
criminality and the evil choices that he
made to a person everybody said he was
an incredibly loving father and uh
that's something that um i can really
identify with and and relate to my my
kids are the most important thing in my
life so that was a real hook and and um
i think you always got to find that
those those bits of connection jamie uh
david simon creator of the wire says
that this is kind of the next chapter in
that story you played a drug kingpin 20
years ago right
what was it like stepping back into that
scene that scenario and do you see this
as a continuation of that that other
story well stepping into
homicide detective sean suiter from
playing marlowe in baltimore maryland
was
was a pleasure only because i get a
chance to one
work with david simon and george again
but two tell a story that's honest and
true it's non-fiction about a city that
suffered the consequences of those
actions
um
it was a transition it was work you know
it was
a level of confidence also because john
spokes said something early on about
just
making sure that you humanize these
characters and keeping them human and
that was the important part to me as
well you know um
because people will look and they'll see
they'll say okay that was marlo in the
city of baltimore yeah um
giving law enforcement work
right right and now he's on the other
side of the spectrum
actually changing it so it was fun
george pelicano's great crime writer
absolutely crime no corruption uh i
heard him say that the the true story of
this gun trace task force may be the
story of the most corrupt police task
force anywhere in the country in history
how did you get your mind around being
part of that on screen well having a
conversation with george pelicanos um
him saying listen you just came off for
seven years just playing a detective on
bosch
um i want you to visit this character as
well so i said can i read some material
some source material on him he sent me
the book and i couldn't put it down are
you guys worried about how police will
perceive this series john look
these are i mean these issues of our day
these are as sensitive
and volatile issue as as you can
possibly explore and i think that these
issues uh deserve to be explored for all
their nuance for all their layers and
and we're dealing with people who come
after work with this real journalistic
integrity on on this set the truth wins
we we shot the scenes on in the city at
the location a lot of times with the
real folks actually being there uh truth
always prevailed on this set so i think
if you're going to explore these issues
you again you got to dive into the wound
and and and and and and
depicted you know bruises and all and
and you can't pull punches um i just
want to avoid these kinds of issues
these kinds of discussions where you're
just kind of arguing from the polls and
you're flag waving and you have agenda
and and i just i i i i can't imagine a
better group to tell the story with now
i was a huge fan of the wire i watched
all six in this series if you're a huge
fan of the wire you see some
similarities in terms of how they shoot
it and all that kind of thing but when
it came to the wire you were rooting for
everyone the bad guy the good guy the
cops the drug dealers the drug addict in
this i had a real struggle
going who am i rooting for here was that
a struggle in terms of playing these
characters too well you know the beauty
about the wire is that everyone was
flawed right i think that's the approach
that david takes in this as well i mean
i don't have a problem rooting for sean
suiter
but
gail pointed to something real that
jenkins character is so charismatic yes
you know he grabs you as soon as you
come on the scene with that speech
so rooting for him in terms of
entertainment and seeing him display
this character on screen is one thing
but when you really get the entire scope
of the story it's very difficult to root
for
um these individuals because you know
it's true right all i can say guys it's
so good i just intended to watch one
episode just to get a feel for it and
four episodes later i was there and then
i said i got to go to bed but
congratulations thank you
congratulations very well done thank you
guys that is john bernthal that is jamie
hector and the lovely marigold suit i
love that
watch the series premiere i love it
it's called we own this city this monday
on hbo